la prochaine Miss France Miss France
2023 qui va succéder à Diane leer ce
sera évidemment la grande question de
cette soirée qui se tiendra dans le
centre Val de Loire et aujourd'hui on va
découvrir donc les 30 Miss petit récap
on va même pas faire de petits récap
d'ailleurs on va les regarder direct
alors on a la Miss Alsace regardez c'est
Camille se dira je sais que vous adorez
ça chaque année quand on fait voilà le
voilà Camille Segara elle est étudiante
en école de commerce elle est belle
c'est pas mon délire mais c'est pas mon
délire mais attention
regardez elle est maquilleuse elle a 23
ans Oriane
pas mal ma préférée qui c'était la
mienne aussi
d'accord allez-y hein dites-nous aux
favoris de vos Sims Auvergne Alicia euh
ah oui elle est étudiante en management
international j'adore l'international
Guillaume aussi
Auvergne alors c'est pas mon délire non
mais j'adore l'Auvergne Marco Alsace
avec une meuf toi pour dire que tout le
monde sait pas tes délires à mon avis
c'est pas
calme-toi
et pareil vous la connaissez pardon
frère
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant c'est Miss Alsace et vous
c'est Aquitaine avec Kelly Miss
Bourgogne regardez l'infirmière Lara le
Breton très jolie aussi
Enora morale étudiante en imagerie
médicale regardez
[Rires]
Miss centre Val de Loire Coraline
regardez et tu donnes ton géographie
en médecine
le docteur Scheller va vous aider
dans quelques instants bonjour vous êtes
madame
c'est pas mon délire mais étudiante
Marion Navarro la fils du commissaire la
fille du commissaire regardez non mais
regardez Mario les gars moi ça y est moi
aussi je suis mis franchement trop tôt
regardez Indira alibachelière
regardez regardez Shaina
j'aime bien j'aime bien biscuits
attention c'est pas tout de suite mais
il y a mission de doc qui arrive dans un
instant vous allez voir pour l'instant
missile de France Adele Bonamour
regardez regardez elle a 18 ans à
l'école de commerce 18 ans et là Miss
Languedoc Cameron Vallières
c'est pas mon délire mais c'est pas loin
c'est pas sur aucune des meubles c'est
ton délire vraiment envie de les mecs
alors attention dans un instant reste
avec nous à venir Miss Lorraine on y va
pour l'instant c'est Miss Limousin
Salomé Maud diplômé d'un master en
management des achats
[Musique]
moi ça y est je suis passé sur Miss
Lorraine ah vous avez changé Miss
Lorraine ça y est moi Michka
elle est chargée de conformité dans le
secteur de l'investissement
et c'est important d'investir c'est
important d'investir moi c'est pas mon
délire mais
à venir attention Miss Midi-Pyrénées
très très fort elle vient de Toulouse
Martinique très belle aussi Axel
regardez étudiant ton géoscien c'est
planétologie alors moi j'adore les
planètes je vais quand même lui dire
Axel mais bon voilà
Florence de mortier kinésithérapeute
regardez
c'est la fille de Sébastien
Miss Normandie regardez et
très belle attention à venir je vous le
dis Miss Pays de la Loire
Calédonie 26 ans
Océane Le Goff ouais diplômé en gestion
et commerce
tout comme Emma Gibert qui n'est pas mon
délire Miss Pays de la Loire regardez je
vous laisse regarder
attention Bérénice Legendre Miss
Picardie très très belle 26 ans 26 ans
aussi être alors c'est pas mon délire
mais magnifique marine Pollet Miss pas
tout Charente 20 ans étudiante en BTS
Esthétique c'est important regardez non
mais regardez magnifique et on a Shanna
Goyon 18 ans bachelière
Shanna
Miss Réunion elle m'a interpellé
Marion Marie Moutou
Miss Rhône-Alpes
elle est étude en doctorat d'experts
comptable au commissaire rencontre
Miss Roussillon carafontaine étudiant en
psychologie
Saint-Barthélémy Inès
étudiant en cinématographique alors on
va revoir s'il vous plaît on va revoir
les favoris vannes de chacun on va voir
les favoris de chacun Gilles s'est mise
Guadeloupe parce qu'on peut la revoir
s'il vous plaît voilà pour Gilles c'est
Miss Guadeloupe c'est ça favorite
pour Daniel c'est misaken et pour Kelly
aussi
Côte d'Azur oui voilà je crois qu'il se
passe un truc entre les mois quoi
il les a pas vu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est quoi toi la première
parce qu'elle est simple elle est
fraîches elle est elle est pas maquillée
tout est à elle elle a une belle semaine
quand tu portes quelque chose c'est que
c'est à toi non non là tu dis pas il y
en a qui rajoute des choses je pense que
elle va nous rajoutera